und wir wollen jetzt schalten zur
krankenschwester bilder redlich guten
morgen frau redlich sie sind
krankenschwester habe ich gerade schon
gesagt und sie sind sehr wütend auf die
politik warum das und morgen hier habe
ich bin sehr wütend auf die politik ist
einfach nichts passiert und diese zulage
franzose schlichtweg nicht bekommen wir
sind einfach angelogen
das macht mich
ja und gerade jetzt in der pandemie wird
ja ihr job noch wichtiger wie haben sie
dann während der pandemie arbeiten
müssen und wir haben natürlich schon
ganz gut muss man sagen
natürlich waren die mitarbeiter
gestresst und ja es gegen aber es war
natürlich schon eine heraus
wie sieht denn ihr beruflicher alltag
aus willich könnte das so ein bisschen
überschreiben und auch die belastung
konkret wir arbeiten natürlich es ist
einfach minderwertige bezahlung ist
immer so ein halt decke geht stetig
zurück und spanien fast einfach das
personal an die patienten ein
man hat immer mehr zu versorgen und das
ist schlichtweg nicht nur möglich es ist
teilweise alles sich gastieren auf
station machen
haben sie denn das gefühl dass sie und
auch im beruf wertgeschätzt werden
nein unser beruf wird nicht
wertgeschätzt wir haben jetzt ein
dokument etc wir haben dann hat für uns
geklatscht auch welches es gibt neben
man hat uns mittlerweile
bei den streik geht es ja um mindestens
150 euro mehr gehalt erreicht dass die
frage ist immer was ist gerecht für
diesen beruf natürlich sind 150 euro
nicht schlecht aber es ist natürlich bei
weitem nicht die hand die einige regeln
die soft verdient da müsste man schon
ordentlich was auf packen um den beruf
attraktiver zu gestalten spricht dass
auch wird und nachwuchs und dankeschön
frau redlich für ihre informationen und
alles gute für sie
vielen dank mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren